image generation is one of the hardest
advancements in recent AI technology and
it's now possible for anyone to create
their own realistic images with just a
few clicks using generative AI studio in
Google Cloud if you're not already
familiar with image generation this is
the technology where you can feed an AI
Model A text description or prompt of
what you want and the AI will generate
brand new images that match that prompt
and now you can use and build with this
technology in generative AI Studio on
vertex AI to get started we'll navigate
to generative AI studio and click
through to Vision now we enter our
prompt which describes the image we want
to generate
and hit submit an array of images will
be generated so you can take your pick
of which ones you like best and there
you have it you can directly export and
use these images for your content apps
or marketing campaigns be sure to check
out the rest of generative AI studio and
comment below how you're going to use
the new image generation features